candace i want straight answers
rapid fire would you rather okay
[Music]
number one would you rather have tea
with cardi b or brunch with meghan
markle
tea with cardi b in a second really
absolutely i thought that would be more
difficult oh my gosh meghan markle she's
just unbearable moaning markle i just
can't she just would be like hey i'm a
victim because they're blowing like
cardio like
i would understand what she was saying
and she'd be funny at least she'd be
kind of funny she'd just be making
noises you know and i'd be like what are
you doing
it's such an interesting noise you're
making yes
you know so i'm i'm taking cardi b and t
over
number two would you would you rather
permanently move to los angeles
or the other thing or well or
permanently move
to new york oh gosh this is
this is me we're talking about de blasio
yeah this question we're talking about
new york okay rats in new york or
another kind of rat in los angeles
rats everywhere it's everywhere ah gosh
i hate to say this
i think oh my god this is really hard
it's hard
i actually do think there's a correct
answer los
angeles wow yeah i have to disagree only
because the rats have got i don't think
you've seen that
i lived in new york for seven years and
like the rats were already big and
during covent
and now they've taken over the city and
honestly they're so
big yeah and just i just that is
that is true no i okay fair enough uh
number three
would you rather have your book canceled
on amazon
or have harry styles be your running
mate when you run for president
um i will take harry styles as my
running mate
because he has a dedicated fan base i
mean
i received pictures of men in dresses
for three weeks after i said he
shouldn't wear a dress yes and i think
we could use that kind of enthusiasm on
the ground
and look i mean he knows how to how to
wear a dress
and it's going to be great for you know
first dance
is it usually the president and the vice
president you know it would be good too
because then
when you win he could become the second
female vice president he definitely
could
impress and so i'm taking harry uh
number four
would you rather have aoc direct your
new show or
wear a mask through 2029 oh
i will take aoc directing my new show
because she's
so uneducated it's funny so i think we'd
have a we'd have a fun time on set with
aoc
and she's also good at show business
yeah she is very good business
she knows her life yeah exactly and
she's an actress so she knows what she's
doing it's true yeah it's a no-brainer
yeah it's just a no-brainer aoc
okay would you rather have a cigar
right now with me after this show or
some wine wine wine husband does the
cigars i don't know i was hoping
yeah that's right okay is for the
husband yeah by the way how is
how is that a bit sexist when it comes
to the cigar and the wine
awful i'm not surprised with all of your
faux phobias and isms i'm not surprised
speaking of the cigars and the wine and
the husband and the kid how's it all
going
it's going great i have all four in the
house at the moment so i've got the kid
the husband the cigar and
the wine cellar which is awesome but i
love wine i'm definitely and i
appreciate why i'm not when i say i love
wine i don't mean it i'm like the
oh my god i have so many feelings right
now and this is a girl runs in some wine
um i have like a deep appreciation for
wine i
i love it more in the former way yeah
i can just talk to my girlfriends
well you bring the wine i'll bring the
feelings thank you
thank you for the would you rather i am
i feel as though i know you even more
deeply than i did before
i felt like the new york la question was
a little racist
well there it goes now we're canceled